in order to help the garbage collector
do its job you want to be sure you're
not holding onto objects that you no
longer need the easiest way to do this
is to use an appropriate scope for your
variables instead of using a global
variable that you then have to
dynamically allocate and de-allocate
just use a function scope local variable
when it goes out of scope the garbage
collector can take care of it
also be sure to unbind any event
listeners before the dom objects they're
bound to are to be
removed and finally if you're using a
local data cache be sure to clean the
cache or using aging mechanism to avoid
any large chunks of data being stored
that you don't really need anymore